book TV continues now Jane Mayer
discusses her most recent book dark
money the hidden history of the
billionaires behind the rise of the
radical right she'll talk about all her
books and answer your questions live on
in depth next Sunday March 6 at 12:00
p.m. Eastern evening everyone
hi I'm Jeff root and Beck I'm the Dean
of the School of Communication welcome
to the MALDI dial and michael foreman
theater here at AU this is part of our
ongoing media that matters series which
we are so pleased to present tonight
this special event and also welcome our
friends at c-span and the book talk
audience I'm here to introduce Chuck
Lewis nationally known investigative
journalists former ABC News and 60
minutes producer best-selling author and
founder of several nonprofit
organizations including the
investigative reporting workshop here at
the School of Communication and before
that the Center for Public Integrity
Chuck's most recent book 935 lives the
future of truth and the decline of
America's moral integrity and he was
counting 935 is a fascinating
exploration of the many ways truth is
manipulated by governments and
corporations and opened an important
national conversation Chuck is also the
author of the well known book series the
buying of the president a chilling look
into the financing and presidential
campaigns written with staff from the
Center for Public Integrity Chuck is a
full-time professor here in the School
of Communication and teaches
investigative journalism and he recently
returned from a fellowship at the
University of Oxford Reuters Institute
for the Study of journalism tonight he's
going to have a conversation with Jane
Mayer someone who has spent five years
researching the influence of dark money
in our political system a passion that
Chuck shares Chuck
very much Jeff and welcome everyone and
Jane welcome very much to American
University I by way of introduction and
we'll start talking but up to introduce
Jane we would take ten minutes just to
go through her bio which is an
astonishing bio you know whether
preeminent journalist in the US The New
Yorker now 11 years Stanford to a many
years so I shouldn't ask several years a
few years and yeah
and anyway literally winner of so many
words John Chancellor word George Polk
award Turner prize for excellence
including reporting the if' stone medal
for journalistic independence and of
course the Jay Anthony Lucas prize
Goldsmith Book Prize Ridenhour Prize
other that's for an earlier book the
dark sign I think but numerous awards
and so but I urge those of you who
should absolutely buy this book dark
money read the bio too but it's just
pretty interesting bio so welcome and
where do we start here since we have
several aspiring or recurrent students
they're all students or many are
students but they aspire to be jane
mayer could you please explain to us
where you come from and with that whole
stories about i mean seriously how did
you end up causing all this trouble this
is work yes okay well part of what got
me on this trajectory i have to say is
true so truck you were some of the
inspiration for this book I kind of
remember an iced tea
as we were talking I was working on a
story for the New Yorker magazine about
the cokes and they'd caught my eye for a
variety of reasons that we can talk
about in a minute but I just wanted to
say that Chuck Lewis as I was talking to
him over this iced tea gave me this
quote that was kind of the money quote
for the whole piece and sort of was the
thing that made me think okay there may
be more here even when I'm doing a book
okay so so so professor Lewis has
exactly the right quote and it says the
cokes are on a whole different level
there's no one else who has spent as
much money
the sheer dimension of it is what sets
them apart they have a pattern of law
breaking political manipulation and
obfuscation I've been in Washington
since Watergate and I've never seen
anything like it
they are the Standard Oil of our times
that quote Wow you know and when I read
that quote I kind of think like why did
I spend five years and 450 pages adding
to it you kind of thumbed it up you fell
so I want to thank you you've been an
incredible colleague amazingly generous
a we set the path on how to cover the
cokes and the work that you've done here
and in the other work you've done and in
following money and power in America and
so and and how I got into this you know
and like most things it started
innocently I turned a corner in New York
City at one point where I grew up and
saw David Koch's name on the Conn
Lincoln Center and I thought David Koch
and it kind of rang a bell and I
remembered wow there I read a story
about them too putting money into the
Tea Party somewhere and I thought I
wonder if New Yorkers they're
sophisticated Manhattanites who are the
people who go to Lincoln Center have any
idea who David Koch really is and I
wasn't sure who he was either at that
point but I thought it was worth taking
a peek and that kind of so it was it was
crossing that Street I think going
around the corner that got me going on
this
and one thing led to another and that
how five years went down the drain so
but I'm not going to let you wriggle out
of the question either thank you for the
kind words if there are the standard of
all of our times and I still very much
believe that that would make you Ida
Tarbell one of my hero I write I mean
you have dogged lis investigated this
subject unlike any other journalist and
and I'm it was inevitable we would
discuss this I didn't know at what point
we would bring it up while we're at it
not only did you devote all these years
and obviously upset them and it's
reported I think you mentioned your book
that when your or your article the
article about citizens united in August
30th 2010 and the New Yorker was
actually nominated for a National
Magazine Award and they've mounted a
campaign against you but you had some
additional dealings with them that have
been chronicled recently in the New York
Times I'm sorry to ask you but clearly
they're not as that well they are
perhaps equally interested in you but
maybe you could describe that whole
story because it's an amazing story and
not every that's a badge of honor I
think for any investigate reporter what
you're hopefully will tell us well thank
you it was an unexpected byproduct of
writing about The Kooks which was to me
an interesting investigative piece I
cover politics for the New Yorker
magazine and inevitably politics means
covering money and the cokes were you
cannot cover money and politics without
stumbling across them at this point they
are such a concentrated force
financially in American politics so I
basically was going about my job but
when I finished the story and it came
out they they had declined to
participate they declined to give
interviews and I guess they you know we
can say they were not happy with it it's
too bad but I felt it was a very good
piece and captured the kind of
subterranean
roll they were playing in the in
American politics and they'd been very
much in the shadows so it wasn't
surprising really that they didn't give
me an interview they they have been
secretive for many years and so anyway
they they were unhappy with the peace
and I discovered I began to hear strange
things I began to hear that there was a
private eye poking into my life and I
first thought it was kind of funny
because I'm married have kid a dog
pretty settled life and not that
interesting I thought the poor private
eye but but anyway and I kind of just
laughed it off and then I was at a
Christmas party and a colleague said to
me who had been a reporter you know a
couple billionaires have hired a private
eye to look into a reporter who wrote a
story that they didn't like about them
and they're looking for dirt and they
asked me if I might work on this too and
she said and I'd occurred to me that
might be you and so I thought oh that's
weird
and then anyway I've been very soon
after I discovered that actually there
had been a kind of an opposition
research project on me and that the
couple top people at Koch Industries in
Washington had organized it and they had
hired private I who turned out to be the
police commissioner in New York City
Howard safer and the former police
commissioner not current exactly with
his son and a daughter who'd been in the
FBI and they have a private firm in New
York and I eventually pieced together
the story just as a reporter would and
we found a source who told me they were
looking for dirt dirt dirt and if they
couldn't find it they'd make it up and
so they had actually made something up
they came to they put together a story
saying that I was a plagiarist and they
tried to peddle it to a couple news
organizations neither which would run it
because it turned out not to be true
but it would have been pretty terrible
if it had gotten and to print and anyone
believed it luckily nobody ran with it
and the reporters whose work I was
supposed to have ripped off
great and they sent stood up for me and
said it's untrue and and and nobody
therefore could publish this but it was
eye-opening I mean truthfully I can look
back on this now and almost say wow it's
kind of flattering that they took me
that seriously but truthfully it's it's
the card ball that you don't see that
often I've covered a lot of different
things I've covered Wars covered the CIA
has covered several white houses
politics at every level and nobody's
ever done that before so it was it was
eye-opening in terms of showing you the
kind of unaccountable power that these
private billionaires can have in America
where they throw around their ways to
try to control the Free Press from
covering them as honestly as I possibly
could which is what I was trying to do
you know I learned when I was doing more
research that I was far from alone it
the cokes of hired private eyes for all
kinds of things whenever people have
challenged them they've had privatized
look into the FBI when the FBI was
investigating coke industries they've
gone after federal prosecutors who were
looking into them they've actually hired
private eyes to look into their own
brothers because there are actually four
Koch brothers and they've broken into
two teams of two and the two teams of
two have litigated against each other
for at least 20 years because they were
fighting over who was going to get the
biggest share in the family company and
the family fortune and in the course of
that it got so brutal that they hired
private eyes on each side to look into
each other's garbage so it's it's a it's
a company that is remarkable it's
remarkably successful and remarkably
hardball playing right you say the
Standard Oil of our time right my in my
sort of impious sense of humor when the
attempt to destroy you
occurred the two outlets one in
particular was so anxious to get
something out of the hits online of the
word Koch
that they they actually the headline I
think was smear job gone bad gone wrong
there was one that said smear disappears
I like this better she'd the truth is
that was the New York Post which I and
the New York Post it kind of did a good
job Keith Kelly since we're talking
about journalism they could have just
said oh well that's weird
and gone away they did not that Keith
Kelly who covers the media at the New
York Post thought well that's strange
here's this reporter who didn't
plagiarize and I was being told that she
did I wonder who's behind this and it
was there were sort of a number of
intermediaries in between so you
couldn't really tell who was behind it
and he kept pushing at it and as he said
recently it was a pretty short list of
suspect and it eventually got you know
took a long time but it got back to Koch
Industries and this private eye that
they had hired so and so whack back when
you and I were talking a few years ago
we did a project at the investigative
porting workshop called Coke Club the
Coke Club and we we had 28 people
working on that over two and a half
years and one of the things was about
climate change legislation dying in
Congress namely the House of
Representatives and there were so many
things that tumbled out of that
switching gears here clearly sorry but I
could I mean it's not just a bunch of
dilettante billionaires here they're the
in addition to trying to smear
journalists I mean can you talk about
the impact I mean the Obama
administration came into power one of
the things they wanted to do was enact
climate change legislation oil and gas
contributions and lobbying doubled in
the two years cycle that was the 2008
presidential cycle that Obama came in on
partly because they were worried about
him and as we both know it died in the
House of Representatives and there was
there's all kinds of reasons for that
and is that a good place to jump off it
because I I think we would people lose
sight of it's not just the atmospherics
and kind of the unusual thing about two
billionaire brothers it's also the
impact
that they and their other billionaire
friends have brought to bear its impact
I mean and it's also I mean I'm glad you
asked about this because it's not just
about elections we're obviously in an
election year and that's what
everybody's focused on but but Coke's
these two particular billionaires have
joined with 400 or 500 others
spectacularly wealthy conservatives many
of whom have serious financial interests
in front of the US government and they
have pooled their resources to some
extent and created a project which has
great influence over American policy and
one of the policies they have affected
the most is anything having to do with
climate change these many of the big
interests in the Koch groups including
the Koch themselves our fossil fuel
interests their bottom line depends on
fossil fuels they are oil refiners and
they've got coal and they've got gas and
they've got pipe lines and so anything
that moves the United States away from
fossil fuels is a threat to their
business model and they have played it's
just a really thorough game of trying to
capture Congress and make it follow in a
direction that's good for their business
which meant as you were talking about
2010 2011 they the Congress was
considering a bill to a cap-and-trade
carbon emissions but it basically put
some kind of price on carbon pollution
and the reason it didn't work in great
measure was because the cokes and other
fossil fuel interests just clobbered
anybody who was going to support it and
they worked very hard to take out
particularly conservative Democrats and
moderate Republicans who might have
strayed from the orthodox line that they
set which is to say climate change isn't
real or doesn't matter or we can't
afford to do anything about it
right and and the bill to put climate
change through the House of
Representatives ends up dying and
something like ninety or a hundred I
forget the numbers of House members all
Republicans who had signed this pledge
know climate tax pledge I think it's now
one hundred and fifty six hundred fifty
six and no so how does the private
interest um you know a couple
billionaires affect policy the cokes
have an organization called Americans
for Prosperity which is supposed to be a
grassroots citizens group which they
fund founded and helped fund and it
spreads out across the country and it
has a pledge and candidates who want to
get backing from their organizations
have to sign a pledge saying that they
will do nothing about climate change
unless it costs nothing and and so one
hundred and fifty six members of the
Congress at this point have now signed
this pledge it's a private you know
agreement practically with Koch
Industries which is pretty incredible
when you think about it it is and they
also that same year that they did this
with a pledge and blocking the
legislation that they also what they
were all doing other things with
universities enough this is a full-court
press on multiple levels and of course
we attract 221 universities receiving
thirty or forty million dollars from
them in the span of a five year period
which i think is increased since we did
this record and do that am I really the
biggest focus in some ways of Charles
cokes philanthropy yeah I mean this gets
back to I mean this book is called
it's a history hidden history and
there's a history here it's the back
story and I felt as a reporter who
covers stories for a magazine it wasn't
really possible to tell the whole story
without doing this book and even though
it was hard to do and it took a long
time it was to try to connect the dots
that you can't really always see when
you're just reading the daily coverage
or even the magazine coverage the story
is a it goes back for years at least and
there's been a project that Charles Koch
and David Koch have funded for
these four decades to try to really
change the the direction of American
politics Charles and David were about as
far right and his libertarian as you can
get in America back as long ago as 1976
at that point Charles was maybe thirty
year in his 30s and he was saying that
he wanted to found what he called a
movement to to smash and to as he the
word to use was destroy the statist
paradigm which means sort of big
government in America he's a he someone
who really regards government as a form
of tyranny for the most part and
taxation is theft and he wanted to
change the whole set up in kind of
modern America shrink the government get
the government out of the way of
businesses and get the regulations off
of his own business so that started in
1976 and he was trying to think how do
we do it so the first stage and the
obvious thing that you do when you're on
a change politics in America is you run
for office so in 1980 he Charles helped
he's the older brother of David he
helped get David to run as vice
president of the United States on the
libertarian ticket and they ran against
Ronald Reagan and they ran against
Reagan from the right because they felt
Reagan was too much of a liberal so that
gives you an idea where they were on the
political spectrum really far out it was
so far out that even conservatives at
that point like William Buckley were
describing them as a narco totalitarians
I mean they had very very interesting
ideas but they are really kind of
unusual ideas they're not kind of in the
mainstream of American politics and they
certainly were not back then and so in
that 1980 election they did abysmally
the libertarian ticket took something
like 1% of the vote a cost David Koch
millions of dollars of his own fortune
and and he paid for I think 60% of the
whole campaign himself and so they
realized okay we're not going to win it
this way so what do you do then
the cokes are very smart they they're
terrific businessmen they're both
graduates of MIT and they're engineers
and they went back to the drawing board
to try to figure out a new model and in
the years after that pretty soon after
that they began to think drop a
blueprint for how you could do sort of
an assembly line to change American
politics even if you couldn't win the
popular vote they followed the footsteps
of a couple other major
multimillionaires and billionaires on
the right who were also funding this
project and they figured out that from
their standpoint politicians are just
actors who are spouting lines and the
key to changing America is to write the
script so how do you get to write the
script well you have to change kind of
the whole way that elite opinion is
formed in the country there happened
have been right around the same time
just a little bit earlier a paper that
was the blueprint for all of this it was
written by Lewis Powell who became a
Supreme Court justice and he before he
joined the court he wrote a paper that
said conservatives and particularly
corporate conservatives are imperiled in
America because liberals at the time he
wrote the paper were ascendant and he
said you've got to fight back and to do
that you're going to have to capture
elite public opinion again like what the
folks were trying to do and to get that
you're going to have to change a couple
things
the real enemy he said is not the kids
in the street or hippies who are
protesting it's not the anti-war
protesters it's not even the
environmental movement in some ways he
said what you've got to change are the
people who write the editorials of the
newspaper the professors at the
universities the scientists who are
putting out studies but the preachers
and the pulpit and as much as anything
else the judges on the courts well we
can see today why judges on the courts
matter but so this was the kind of good
game plan and and after the
the 1980 election went badly for the
cokes they followed this game plan
pretty closely and began to take their
fortunes but all the all the four sons
in the Koch family had inherited several
hundred million dollars from their
father who had made it in a new process
for how to refine oil they took those
fortunes particularly Charles who is
really the kind of the ideological
leader in the family and began to think
how you're going to change those that
elite public opinion and they funded a
system to do it University programs
think tanks and quite a few other things
and we counted 89 non profit groups
happy names like the center for blue
skies except that's not a real one I
don't think but we actually identified
all of them and as you recall and I
think well it was 30 or 40 million
dollars in a five-year period that that
went to the at least that went to those
groups I could it be more eyeball those
numbers are in the coke Club online for
those of you here 200 excellent way but
I mean it the breath of it it takes is
astonishing the extent of it no one has
ever seen a single group doing this and
it was his five family related
foundations sending money out and we
looked at the 990-pf forms which shows
what donors give out not just what
organizations receive and that's the
only way we could track it but while
their commercial lobbyists were twisting
arms and work in the town about climate
change and other things they cared about
these happy sounding groups were experts
PhDs of course and they were going up to
the hill and testifying that there's
really not a problem about climate
change and they were creating this whole
narrative in all of these hearings House
and Senate that was establishing that
this really is a contested area and
everyone is quite concerned about it and
they didn't say I'm funded by the oil
industry they worked at this you know
the so-called cut out groups third party
entities and and that's not the first
time that's happened in Washington but
no one's ever to my knowledge
89 at one time several dozen of which
we're focused on energy and environment
issues but it creates I mean it creates
the sense that there's a groundswell of
opinion and a chorus of agreement up
there expert agreement when you have
these many different groups all speaking
at once and all these different experts
and really chuck the work you guys did
in particular was fantastic and showing
that that that the experts didn't just
put out papers but they testified on the
hill where of course it becomes you know
part of the expert opinion that guides
legislation and so and what is what was
interesting to me and still is is that
so much of this effort was done as as
charities these are the groups that
these nonprofit groups many of them are
501 C 3s which are charitable
organizations so when when you give a
contribution to them you get a tax
deduction they're supposed to be public
interest groups but there have been
questions raised over the years about
some of the ones the cokes have given to
in particular and have organized in
particular because they serve private
interests as much as anything else they
serve the interests of coke industries
so you have experts out there lobbying
essentially for policies that are good
for their company and take meanwhile the
people who are giving the contributions
the cokes are taking tax deductions for
it all of this is is I mean it's it's
it's mind blowing when you look at the
whole thing altogether and it was hard
to do but you guys did it first while
you're very kind but then there's an
even larger issue not as though we are
not large enough here
the 889 million dollars that the cokes
pledged I think it was Charles pledged
that that they will spend this year
basically regarding the current
presidential election and that level of
money being spent is at the same level
as political parties I mean we've never
seen donors it's not just the cokes now
it's actually scores maybe hundreds of
other exceedingly wealthy folks who have
these periodic mysterious abusing
strange
meetings at fancy hotels and things and
there I've never seen anyone declare
they were going to spend as much as a
political party in a single election the
numbers now and the number of people
that the similar similarly minded folks
who are now joining forces many most of
which which you carefully clearly
document and by the way she names which
is great she names names as there are
all these billionaires and I guess some
of them maybe only have five or six
hundred million which I would reach from
my handkerchief but but but anyway so
and you talk about that and what it all
means and whit's unprecedented right the
story there's just been an explosion and
this is what this other face what we're
talking about is is dark money for the
most part this is the money that's it's
undisclosed and so instead of being the
charitable contributions that go to
these 501 C 3 s they go to a kind of
groups that are called social welfare
groups and they too are not supposed to
be specifically and predominantly
involved in politics but it's become the
kind of the great dodge ever since
citizens united and it's become the
sluice through which secret money flows
and so the cokes magic trick as you say
was not just to put their own fortunes
into this project but they've been
brilliant at it at gathering 400 or 500
others with them and somehow convincing
the others to let them control the
contributions so that they're all pooled
in one place and and and and have huge
throw weight as a result and this pile
of money is now it's just it's unheard
of in American history to have this much
money in one place it's 889 million
dollars is twice what the Republican
National Committee spent in the last
presidential campaign it is it is so
much money that it's a just as such a
distortion really of what was expected
also by the Citizens United opinion I
mean people may forget but when the
Supreme Court decided that opinion the
justices who voted for it including
Kennedy and N Scalia as well thought
that that money was going to be visible
the spending would be transparent you
would see instantly where it was and it
would go up online because of the
internet and so that that would be that
would keep that kind of money from
becoming corrupting it wouldn't be
secret money to the contrary though as
some people have warned in advance most
of that money or an awful lot of it has
gone been been sidelined into these
secret groups where it's being spent in
ways you that reporters even as you know
Doggett is Chuck can't follow it's
pretty hard to figure out where it's all
coming from and and who the original
donors are they keep their names secret
the only reason we know who some of them
are is somebody left a guest list once
and it got out and and every now and
then there's another sort of oops moment
like that and and you begin to see who
are these people so that's that's you
know I I enjoyed trying to figure out
who they were how they made their money
why they were doing the things they were
doing doing and what it was they really
wanted to see the American government do
so as we move into all these things and
2012 the Koch brothers and others many
conservative Republicans were hoping
that Mitt Romney would win he did not
win
they had other candidates they were
flirting with I guess you'd say Christie
chris Christie of New Jersey and Scott
Walker they were intrigued with him and
I can't resist asking you this because
it's not in the book but I am sorry
what's happening now with who are they
backing now exactly because they they
have been interested in a couple of
presidential candidates currently that
they've now dropped out so so I'm kind
of curious because I'm not seeing anyone
obviously noting this and so I'm kind of
curious what what the answer is so it's
so far so they've got this war chest of
potentially 889 million dollars not all
that was supposed to be spent on the
campaign some of it will be spent on
advocacy and it's it's sitting there
they have their
on the sidelines waiting to see which
candidate emerges as the best chance of
knocking off Hillary Clinton basically
and so they have um while they've been
waiting there though a couple of the
candidates that they've liked Scott
Walker in particular has dropped out and
most of the major Republican
presidential contenders have come to
their donor group and begged for the
money and are sort of auditioning for it
so pretty much any of the candidates
would do with one exception though who
must be very perplexing to them and
that's Donald Trump he is it makes a
great point of saying he's a billionaire
in his own right and doesn't need other
billionaires backings and he's even
rudely described the other contenders
who have gone to the donor summits to
beg for the cokes backing he described
them as puppets and so they I think
probably part of his appeal to the
public is that people think that he's
not owned by these private interests he
sort of his his his owned by his own
interest but not by some other interests
so he's they've discussed now whether or
not they should use some of this money
to try to knock out Trump but of course
that's problematical as well because
there could be a backlash from the
voting public if it feels that a small
group of billionaires and multi multi
millionaires are trying to deprive them
of the candidate that they want so
they're they're kind of in a corner
right now and trying to figure it out
wow that's that's somewhat delicious I
think so but legend I would like to say
okay Celeste I mean and then inevitably
so people would say well so seems like
then they don't have that much influence
with their money and and and I I have to
say that that you what you have to look
at with the coaxes sometimes they've won
elections sometimes they've lost
elections but elections are just one
sphere of what they're involved in they
poured money into trying to have the
Republicans take over the house
of Representatives which they were
instrumental in make happen
in 2010 they poured money into the 2014
race to try to have the Republicans take
over the Senate which again they were
instrumental in affecting and but more
than that if even if you look at Trump's
say we'll say he's the outlier take a
look at some of his positions he is
espousing the same orthodoxy about
climate change that the rest of the
Republican candidates are espousing
which is to say he's denying that it
matters or maybe that it's real it's
it's quite amazing the entire Republican
Party is taking a position that's going
in the opposite direction of science and
of the rest of the world and really the
only explanation for that according to
people I interviewed was the money
that's been involved in pushing the
fossil fuel interests that are so
important in pushing the Republican
Party in that direction and the other
part is of the 50 state legislatures and
the states they have between the
gerrymandering that goes on and the
state legislatures they they haven't
just worried about Washington or one or
both houses of Congress or president
they've actually done it a grassroots
thing which is quite extraordinary also
yeah I mean and again I think it gets
back to thinking about the coaxes
engineers they've looked at American
politics as a kind of a system and tried
to figure out what the pressure points
are and how do you get what you want out
of it and one thing you can do one place
where money matters much more than in
presidential politics in a way is at
least it has much more effect is it the
lower level a small amount of money but
goes much further in state and even
local races they've been involved in
some school board races in Colorado and
other kind of local issues they've been
the Koch organization's been fighting
the expansion of Medicaid for instance
in states all across the country and and
and it's been quite effective one other
thing I wanted to say about Trump also
that's interesting to me is while he is
independent of the Koch organization is
not asking for their money Cory
Lewandowski who is the chairman of his
campaign
his last job was working for Americans
for Prosperity the cokes political group
I mean they are they their group acts in
many ways as kind of a training camp for
many people on the right in American
politics at this point you know the
other part that we must note is what's
happened with the money thing I'm sure
you saw the New York Times article in
October that 156 families gave 50%
basically half of all the money given in
the first half of 2015 that we're down
to that many families giving that much
money in the in the course of a
representational representative
democracy so the question is and I'm
also fascinated in 2012 at the end of it
that they're all upset and they're
frustrated because they were
outmaneuvered in their view they start
investing in technology ways to gauge
races in a precise way in a
micro-targeting way and in a way that
they're convinced the Obama folks had
mastered and the Democratic Party you
have a section about a group these new
things like guys I 360 and all these
various things I'm just fascinated
they have also now dumped large sums of
money into the technologies in addition
to all the hundreds of like-minded Souls
they're rounding up who have lots of
money is that bode have is that going to
affect 2016 it sounds like they've
they're girding they've girded for
battle after losing in 12 with
technology at least the way some of the
things you wrote seem to imply yeah I
mean they went back to the drawing board
and tried to figure out what went wrong
after 2012 they were actually shocked I
think that they lost in 2012 right up to
to the afternoon of election day they
thought they were going to win and their
operatives were telling them they were
going to win so it was kind of a you
know crushing blow in some ways and they
did a lot of studying and they realized
they felt that they've been
outmaneuvered in terms of big data which
is you know so important now in politics
and so they have built up a an operation
that many people think is is better than
the one that they're
publican party has again it's as if the
the small group of extraordinarily
wealthy donors is creating almost its
own party a third party and and so
they've got their own get-out-the-vote
operation and ability to sort of have
people going door to door and and and
enter all the data in and you know an
interactive kind of system it's it's
very sophisticated really but more than
that they also I found it really
interesting
they studied themselves after twenty
twelve to try to figure out why it was
that they'd not been successful and they
did a huge amount of market survey
research and they did polls and focus
groups and they came to the conclusion
that they had an image problem and and
very perceptive so they and I know this
because a tape leaked out of them
discussing the it's the Koch operatives
discussing with the donors what they
learned from this research and they
described the problem was that the
public felt that libertarian businessmen
who wanted to slash government services
were greedy and so they felt that they
were misunderstood and they needed to be
seen as virtuous and generous and so
they you can hear them discussing this
they decided that they needed to get
involved in altruistic activities and
they have since that period started
doing many more sort of outreach
programs to the poor they've been giving
out turkeys in some places and they have
formed unusual alliances with liberals
on some issues like criminal justice
reform and they have recast their own
ideology they now describe it very in
they describe it very purposefully not
as just libertarianism
and not just about prosperity but as a
movement for well-being and and so you
will see if there's there's a new sort
of initiative that that Charles Koch
foundation has that it's about
well-being and if you drill down into it
what you'll find is the definition of
well-being for the most part is the free
market from their standpoint so you get
you to the same place but it has a whole
new branding effort and and Koch
Industries meanwhile has put fifteen
million dollars or so a year into fixing
up its image with corporate ads and
that's a new thing for them too so Ann
Weber also started giving out a couple
interviews which they had not done for
many many years so the it reminds me of
Richard Nixon when he ran for president
68 and they they packaged him a
different way it sounds like the new
Nixon the new Nixon do they do coke we
think of it as the new coke yeah right
fact yeah sorry couldn't resist up last
question form and then we'll turn it out
to Quentin we could talk for about two
days on this subject we have a lot of
students in the audience and I'm just
one end also that will be watching later
at some point on c-span I'm sorry to ask
you this but what advice would you give
clearly you were impressed and inspired
by Ida Tarbell but that's that's so last
century and so what you are obviously
one of the preeminent investigative
journalists in the u.s. this book is an
extraordinary book I really recommend it
it's really a stunning read but what
would you recommend to some of our
budding investigative journalists in the
audience in terms of trajectory and
dedication to the profession and all
those things
well III mean I think this whole basic
role of being reporters speaking truth
to power holding people accountable is
just such an important part of democracy
that it's an honor to be in this
profession I really do feel very
privileged to do it and it's not always
easy every day but it's also incredibly
interesting
almost everyday and I guess the other
advice I have is sometimes investigative
reporting can can get to down into the
weeds and it gets confusing to people
and it's hard for readers to read
through so I would also emphasize the
importance even when you're you're
getting all of that complicated data to
tell stories because at the end of the
day it's about real people doing things
that affect everybody's lives
and you've got to remember that if you
people can't read it they're not going
to be able to get your story so you've
got to tell it as a story and I really
believe if you can try to remember that
all people love hearing stories if you
can try to take that information and
make it readable it's it's a real gift
to people that's great
and I have to say that despite all the
facts and the carefully documented every
single sentence every number that you
mentioned that it's well done but it
reads exceptionally well how many drafts
did you have to do to get to that point
so many piles I was just looking at in
my office this morning thank you God can
I throw these out now and I I'm afraid
that I'll be you know something will
happen and I'll need to have still have
them but god I really the dust bunnies
in my house are out of control so anyway
to many drafts right on that note any
questions if you'll wait for the
microphone they're standing by to give
you a microphone not just temporarily
though this one yeah sorry
this gentleman is a town the journalist
who has been part of a team that just
won the George Polk award thank you
there yeah welcome and that
congratulations Derek Hawkins a you grad
student working with Chuck @rw and the
Washington Post
um yeah as you mentioned and as you know
firsthand the coax go after have a
history of going after their opponents
with this Nixon like vengeance I'm
wondering why you think what you think
makes them so vindictive that is a
really good question I think you're in
the light right line of work definitely
um you know I think I mean it's hard to
psychoanalyze people who you haven't
been able to actually even interview so
I'm loathe to try to get into their
heads specifically but I can say that a
number of these people who are huge
donors who are very involved in American
politics and have just unfathomably
large portions are used to getting their
way they are used to controlling the
circumstances around them and being told
yes by the people who work for them and
the press can be and seem impertinent we
ask the rude questions that they don't
want to answer and we examine the
documents that they don't want us to see
and I think it's to some extent in the
front to their their sense of control
maybe and that's why they think that
that they need to sort of come at you so
hard they're used to controlling their
image and controlling much else the Koch
Industries is a privately owned company
so they don't even have stockholders so
they don't have to answer very many
public questions at all so the press
really is is it's a it's playing a role
that they don't really wish to have to
deal with I think and if that helps that
sounds about right
um yes a professor John Sullivan of and
senior editor of the investigative
reporting workshop and Pulitzer Prize
can I just say one other thing I was
thinking yeah out one other thing is you
know I can say from from having seen the
the things that the Koch say about the
press that they were shocked that they
were getting tough coverage and they
regard themselves as private citizens
and not public figures and I think
that's what may be part of the problem
also because to people like me who cover
politics it's so obvious that they are
public figures playing huge public roles
at this point but they had
regarded themselves as just ordinary
citizens who happen to be billionaires
so so I was very interested to hear you
talk about the question about you know
seeing how much money the cooks have put
into the election process in all these
other ways they try to influence thought
leaders and talking about well what's
the what's the real result of that been
and so I was wondering and you talked
about real people and how it affects
real people could you can you talk about
kind of how their influence over the
past 20 years might have changed our
daily lives and then secondly can you
talk about what is there how how far
into the future are they looking are
they playing a very long game and what
is this kind of strategy going forward
for them well they have been playing a
very long game since it goes back to at
least you know 1976 I think with Charles
and earlier really because he was
involved in things before that so it has
they've had a very long horizon they're
very committed to it it's not it's not
something they're dilettante ish about
they've really put their fortunes into
this and particularly Charles has and so
he's a very you know important force in
American politics and thinking even
though he's been under the surface for
much of this time what the way one of
the things that I think that they have
worked hardest at is trying trying to
convince Americans that government is
evil that it is a not a force for good
to have an activist government but the
government is is in itself of an evil
influence and so this song isn't
investigative reporters do we have our
we there's some parts of the government
we too have found to be evil influences
every now and then but they put this
whole issue of regulations being either
they define Liberty as the lack of
government in many ways and so public
opinion has changed a lot about the
government and they have contributed a
lot to that it's hard to measure how
much of it is is you know they're doing
but that this is basically if you boil
down their message
their message is government is bad
private industry is good regulations are
bad they've been pushing for instance to
abolish the EPA since the EPA was
started
they've been against Social Security
since it was started there have been
against Medicaid and Medicare since they
were started they so when you hear the
current Republican candidates saying we
should get rid of the EPA or get rid of
the IRS that's another thing the cokes
have been pushing for for for decades
that's very much their their way of
thinking and it would seem too
outlandish when people first said it but
now it's they've been very good at
injecting these ideas into the
mainstream of American politics so how
does that affect people's everyday lives
when when regulations are weakened
environmental regulations are weakened
or nothing's done about climate change
or Congress is tied up in knots and is
dysfunctional dysfunction in some ways
is good from the standpoint of
libertarians because they don't really
want the government to do very much and
in fact I have a quote from someone in
here saying the gridlock is our best
friend and so so when you see Congress
tied up in knots that affects much of
America but it's it's it's also
something that the cokes and the
libertarians that have really fought
hard to have a very radical program
against spending don't feel so bad about
in fact they've helped push it there
does that help I don't know thank you
great then way in the back here but hold
on till you get the mic Thanks
I'm sorry well whichever one you want to
do there yeah hi my name is Duncan
Gilchrist and I'm a senior at American
University and I'm actually part of a
student organization it's a grassroots
organization called uncloak my campus
and we are working to sort of publicize
the ways that the Charles Koch
foundation is really um as you've
documented in your book seeking to fund
the universities and think tanks in ways
that sort of help them achieve their
political strategy and so given that you
know all of us in this room are sort of
part of both I'm assuming in some way
tied to this like American University
community I was wondering you know if
you could speak to maybe the
responsibility that we have as
participates participants in this
community of the University that is sort
of in a way foundational to their their
funding strategy or their side their
lobbying strategy so what might be our
responsibility as members of you know
institution like American University to
address this this issue well as a
reporter on all in favor of transparency
especially about money and and so I
think it's it's great to try to take a
look at donations from donors that might
not be putting strings attached to those
donations because what you want to be
doing is having as a student you want to
be exposed to many points of view but
you don't want to be having propaganda
come at you that's that's subsidized by
people with private interests that
aren't disclosing it and so I think the
most important thing is to just get
disclosure so you can see who's funding
what why are they funding it and whether
they put any strings on it the cokes
have recently in the last sort of I
guess 10 years you've looked at the
academic programs carefully they've
really stepped up their funding of
academic programs and they regard the
Charles cokes written about this and
talked about it they were
guard students as the future of course
and they see them as the most importance
of stepping stone to spreading their
word and and and you is basically
putting into effect the policies that
they want to see so they in a leaked
tape that came out the same tape that I
described earlier that the Koch
operatives talked about how they have a
talent pipeline and it starts in the
universities and they recruit the most
promising students and they take them
and then help get them internships and
summer program jobs and then they place
them in some of their political
organizations in states around the
country the state they've got the policy
think tanks at the state level and then
they have national think tanks so it's
kind of like a farm team sort of
situation and they describe it as an
unrivaled
unified network basically and and and
it's really interesting again it's a
kind of a systemic comprehensive
approach to change and students
recruiting students is very important to
it when we were doing the Koch club
project with the twenty-eighth folks at
mostly 20 plus students we we knew that
George Mason University of the Mercatus
Center and others had received tens of
millions of dollars from from the
foundations what we did not know is that
American University had received some
funding not a huge amount when we looked
at it was eighteen thousand dollars in
that period I think when we came out
with it in eleven that was a total and
we we got it what happens you get a tax
document it lists all the folks that the
foundations these five foundations I had
had given money to and if you know
there's old cartoons where the person's
eyes come out of their head that day
that was our reaction to the American
University and it was to koga school
business I guess teaching about free
enterprise or something like that well
being well being that well do as well as
yes but they it's not just of course the
cokes have been there a number
big conservative foundations that very
much focused on academia which they saw
as a liberal force that they needed to
change sort of the elite public opinion
in and so you've got the Olin Foundation
and the Bradley Foundation are huge
funders as well and and and there's some
quotes from people who were involved in
them in this book where they talked
about how if they conservative sort of
intellectuals were race cars of going
around the track they would all be
wearing these you know the the insignia
of these foundations on them because and
many of the great books on the right
that have changed American thinking you
know the closing of the American mind or
whatever and Dinesh D'Souza and many of
the sort of more colorful spokesmen that
we all see Ann Coulter and Laura
Ingraham and many others all got their
start with funding from these
foundations Wow and so they freely they
have kind of created their own experts
or as others have called it echo chamber
in echo chamber but it's all or
encounter intelligentsia you know it's
it's it's it's really interesting it's
been a 40-year project is the thing
that's so striking and and now I mean
your campus and others are sort of at
the forefront of it right and and
honestly the the so-called other side
the laughter you know democratic-leaning
capital D leaning folks or don't think
in 40 year increments in terms of
they're there at least they're not known
for that but let's hold that thought the
poor gentleman back there has been very
very patient so if we get a mic back to
you if you have it perfect thanks hi I'm
Donna demand a you grad fellow at the
Washington Post I'm curious to hear more
about your process for getting with
Lufkin sources to talk to you throughout
the throughout the last five years and
to also curious about the length you
want you to try and actually interview
the coax so yeah I mean the lengths I
went to obviously were not successful in
terms of trying to get the coax to to
speak to me though I did manage in their
absence to try to
I make up for them by reading pretty
much everything they've said and written
and interview police and everybody from
kids they grew up with went to school
with people they worked with people they
liked people who did they didn't like
competitors anybody I could get my hands
on who had an experience as the end some
kind of information about them I would
just try to talk to and at a certain
point after several hundred interviews a
kind of a consistent picture came
together so I was able to feel that I
could you know pretty much do an
accurate job I still would love to have
their there in you know be the chance to
interview them but the thing about
Charles Koch is he's pretty much the the
major major driver on the political
front on this he hasn't changed his
opinions that much in 40 years so you
can become pretty familiar with how he
thinks and what he says just by reading
all the things that he said because
they're consistent all the way through
so I I did that and in terms of trying
to talk to them I sent emails I talked
to their lawyers I talked to their PR
people tried to talk to them either on
the record off the record in any way
possible you know that they would feel
comfortable doing it and you know I
think it's it's better if you can get to
everybody when you're doing a story but
at the same time in a way even more
importantly I think it's really
important not to give up the idea of
doing a story and writing about
something just because people won't
cooperate with you
you really can't give them that kind of
control over what story is worth telling
because many people don't want to talk
but they may be doing something that the
public really needs to know about and so
I think it's very important to persist
anyway yeah we have at least two here
yeah we'll start here and come up that
way hi I'm David I'm a senior
American University undergrad my
question is about the current campaign
we're seeing the success of candidates
that maybe aren't spending that much
money or rather people like Jeb Bush who
have spent a ton of money not being
successful in this campaign so can you
speak to why money and politics seems to
be not working as well now and what the
impact may be for that might be well
it's I mean it has been interesting I
think first of all Bernie Sanders for
instance has a different model he is
raising a ton of money but he's raising
it from small donors so it's it's an
another way to get a lot of money
whether you can you know buy your way
into it just with money if you if you're
a candidate that's not convincing to the
public I mean I think it's a pretty hard
thing to do particularly at the
presidential level the presidency is
probably the hardest item to buy in
American politics because presidents
it's not just that it's so expensive
presidents get so much free media so
much attention that that whatever you
can buy in the way of ads is just a drop
in the bucket compared to the amount of
attention that they have anyway the
public sees these candidates and they
it's pretty hard to change people's
minds only by with money if if the
public is really against somebody so you
know but that said you couldn't be in
that ballpark if you didn't have a
tremendous amount of money
all of them have raised all of us the
people who were looking at now who were
still really at the top of the polls
have huge amounts of money and and it
you you that since it's it's it's not
possible to run right now without it so
whoever whoever gets the nomination and
actually the next president itíd stage
each of the two major candidates who
have raised in excess of 750 billion
dollars which is yet again another
record we have records every four years
and so it is essentially an arms race
the two candidates who raise the most
money from their respective parties in
2015 calendar year
were Jeb Bush and the Republican side
and Hillary Clinton in every election
the last quarter century from 76 to 2000
so the year before every one every
candidate who was eligible for matching
funds that raised the most money got the
nomination of their party without
exception for a quarter century starting
in the first part of the decade of the
century of the first ten years from 2000
on we started to see a breakdown of
matching funds of people adhering to
limits and all kinds of other issues and
so we are in a place now that we have
not really seen in decades
this year amounts of money and not just
the sheer amounts but you also have
these outside forces that are spending
more than the parties even and then
meanwhile we have a congress where half
of the members are millionaires and only
5% of the american people are
millionaires so we have increasingly
skewed towards the money in every
department and so we just have to stay
tuned and watch you had a question yeah
thanks hi my name is Shana I'm an
undergraduate freshman at American
University realistically are the Koch
brothers and Powell correct in thinking
that really the only way to make change
in politics is by controlling the elite
and where the money is
are we naive in thinking that the masses
can truly participate in political
democracy especially looking forward in
2016 and years ahead well I mean I'm
someone who loves American history and
so I would say looking over the the
recent American political history that
mass movements can make a tremendous
difference and it's only it's I think
that the the elite donors who had very
far-right views took that course because
they couldn't convince the public of
their their point of view and they
wanted to impose minority views on the
majority and they couldn't just convince
them in the usual way but I think public
the public outpouring for Obama for in
was not something that was driven
necessarily by elite donors and I think
there have been many mass movements that
in my lifetime I've seen that anti-war
movement and other things that have had
tremendous effect on the country the
environmental movement that were not
necessarily funded by a few elite big
donors or anything like that so I'm
actually relatively optimistic about the
ability of the public to change politics
I think it takes activism and engagement
though and and and one of the things
that's most worrisome is just that the
public's getting so cynical about it
that in participation in voting for
instance in the in the last election in
2014 I guess was just incredibly 36% 6%
I mean that's pathetic
so you know that it takes people being
involved and I think a lot of people are
are really sort of despairing of things
right now thank ya come next you're next
and then it may be actually your next
time today I'm Marlene Connors and I'm a
chronically concerned citizen I wanted
to ask you two questions first of all in
your research where you and unable to
uncover any information about the
influence on the Supreme Court in such
decisions as citizens united or Gore V
Bush and the second question is what do
you think motivates the Koch brothers is
it purely money or are there other
motivations as well so there's a chapter
in the book about citizens united that
pretty much fills in the backstory of
how a small group of very wealthy donors
for quite a long time before citizens
united was hoping to break down the
campaign finance limits and and it's a
history of them trying one lawsuit after
the next after the next and building up
some of these nonprofits that would
fight that issue so there is there
certainly was more to it and a kind of a
very concerted effort behind that but in
terms of
what motivates the cokes you know this
is a question that again it's really
hard to know the answer to without being
able to put them on a you know and it
the couch somehow III believe after
spending so much time reading what they
say and have written that they are true
believers in the ideology that they are
pushing and I think though that if you
look at the ideology that they are
pushing there's almost no daylight
between it and and their self-interest
it's it's just that they think that
what's good for Koch Industries is truly
good for America and what's good for
Koch Industries does happen to be really
good for their bottom line and for their
personal accumulation of wealth but they
think that they see themselves as job
creators they see the private sector as
the answer to all most problems they
want to shrink government to sort of as
Grover Norquist once said something you
can drown in your bathtub and and so and
they want to get the regulations off the
backs of businesses including their own
very deliberately they've had all kinds
of environmental pollution problems and
they want to you know push push back
against that so do they really believe
it I think they really believe it but I
think it's also really in their their
self-interest I'm going to keep moving
here Ashley you're up my name is Ashley
Walters ak I'm a master's student here
and a fellow at the Center for Public
Integrity we were talking about how you
were not able to interview the Koch
brothers so I was wondering if you were
to get that interview what is the
question that you would want to ask the
most or is there something that you
couldn't find in your reporting that
you've really been curious about you
know I'm when I do interviews with
people I'm really methodical so what I
would do is go through their whole
chronology in life to try to understand
how it was that they decided to change
all of American politics and why they
thought they needed to and it's such an
ambitious project they've undertaken you
know what what drives them I mean
there's a lot a lot of their early years
are still really mysterious to me why
they why they cared so much to do
this because they were in such a far
fringe spot and they pushed the whole
country as hard as they could to come
their way so I would but I would go I do
things very chronologically methodically
when I questioned people and in your
chronological methodical digging you've
obviously noticed that the coke coke
industries has been fined I believe over
400 million dollars are paid over 400
million dollars in fines and criminal
criminal and civil violations on more
than North America around the world I
mean they I don't know of another
multi-billion dollar corporation that
has been prosecuted quite as much or we
don't we actually don't have a master
list of all the prosecution's of
government does that's a long story
there's three databases they happen to
be strewn all over Washington and
they're not necessarily public that's
another subject but I do think we have a
situation here where usually a company
that has had that many problems the
court settlements with federal judges
and 300 oil spills in one case alone
stealing oil off the Native American
reservations is another case which you
well know and send a book these are not
your usual multibillion-dollar
corporations activities at least I'd
like to think so I'm not saying that
there are lots of problems out there but
I've not never seen anything quite like
this they have a stunning record of
corporate corporate malfeasance they
really do they say they've cleaned up
their act in recent years or they and
but they you know and I think this is
part of the motivation also I mean they
they've been very defiant about how they
the government shouldn't have any right
to regulate them the way that it does on
many of these issues so they're radicals
that's why you know it's the story of
the radical right and I used that word
in the in the title because they define
themselves as radicals there again
they're really unusual people of views
that are so far
out of the center of American thinking
and and they've been proudly sell for a
long time
and in the context of that Vols are kind
of incidental also apparently um anyway
it's my two cents
um any other yeah we have to yeah far
back and far front o dauntless eye on
that policy question about you gave the
great example then on climate change
their influence was able to kill
legislation but do you think they have a
thought on how their apparatus is is
possibly harming efforts to move
criminal justice reform and what what
they would how they would hope that
their influence could actually be
effective in this case when it seems
that they've driven partisanship to a
point that when you need bipartisanship
to pass legislation and they've created
quite a bit of harm well I mean they
would argue I mean that that in fact
their ability to have the Republicans to
their help in having the Republican
Party take over the House and the Senate
then puts them in the driver's seat to a
point where they then can do things like
have bipartisan movements for criminal
justice reform so they would see this as
as something that's enabled them to to
reach out to others so it's it's it it's
it's it's they have a very different
point of view on all of this but
basically they see themselves as a force
for good and you know it's not a view
that everybody has to share though of
all the people and companies you've ever
investigated have you ever run across
one that thinks they're not a force for
good no and and the other thing I have
to say is it is as someone who's written
a lot of stories about people in power
and many in Washington it's very rare
that you get people who acknowledge
they're doing something wrong
for the most part people have a
see to justify what they're doing and
and sort of rationalize it they don't
sit there and say huh I'm going to pull
the wool over on the public they just
sort of sort of slide into saying this
is good for everybody
so I mean it's not unusual to have have
this kind of mindset but it is
irritating well last question here
Thanks hi my name is Tess Larkin I'm an
undergraduate freshman in the School of
Public Affairs my question is we've
reached a point now where we see this
influx of money in politics as a problem
is there any way to solve the problem
the thing that people forget is it
wasn't very long ago
that there was a presidential election
with no private money it was 1980 and
and of Ronald Reagan and Jimmy Carter
both accepted public funding and John
Anderson and John Anderson instead of
taking private funding it's been solved
in the past and and it's not that long
ago it's just that we're at a kind of a
crisis point again it's a it's a it's a
pendulum that swings it's a problem
money obviously just keeps trying to
push its way back into the system
because there's so many private
influences that would they want to kind
of capture the government and so it
keeps pushing and then and then the
Reformers push back but at this point
the pendulum is swung really far in the
direction of of spending as much as
anybody wants and I think it's kind of
at a boiling point yeah we went I think
things can be done and have been done
and can be done again that's right I I
agree they can be done it we went from W
Clement stone giving two million dollars
2.1 to Richard Nixon in 1970 to the year
the the Watergate scandal began and
ended two years later and we now have
two brothers and and like-minded folks
giving 889 million to to control and
influence the current election if you
adjust for inflation you'll notice it's
still astonishingly high
so it wasn't that way beyond what we
might realize now Watergate if you
adjust for and Watergate was considered
a scandal so the kind of the mystery is
why is this not considered a bigger
scandal I actually would argue though
that partly what's going on right now in
this election is that the public is
seeing it as a scandal and is disgusted
and that that actually explains some of
the popularity of both Bernie Sanders
and I think Donald Trump I think there's
kind of a public reaction against the
idea that the candidates are owned and
bought by private interests with huge
money and and and so both of those both
both Sanders and Trump in his own way
have denounced the corruption of money
in politics and I think it shows you
that the public's listening and they
care about it a lot well on that note we
will stop I think just for because I
notice how well people want to purchase
your book and there'll be long lines and
there's no telling I mean it's cheap in
comparison with buying an election yeah
it's very yeah thank you very much and
congratulations
[Applause]